I have followed baseball my life or
cognitive life,
and it really is a fun sport and to me,
the baseball hall of fame as the
greatest hall of fame there is period
into paragraph,
so I wanted to write about it and wanted
to do a book and oversized
coffee table book,
stealing a line from one of the seinfeld
episodes.
It even comes with four legs in case you
need a coffee table.
Book,
Big Pictorial history.
I'm writing the history and I'm taking
the reader on a virtual tour through the
hall of fame and I am proud of the fact
that I got a blurb on the back from Yogi
Berra,
which reads what Bert sugar doesn't know
about baseball.
Nobody knows.
I have no idea what that means.
I think it's Zen.
Might like,
uh,
it's not worth knowing,
but Yogi makes sense.
I'm a Yogi is.
But Yogi,
I once asked you,
I said,
yolks.
What did you mean when you said,
when you come to a fork in the road,
take it.
He said,
that's easy.
I live.
I live at the end of a circle.
Whether you go left to right,
you come to my driveway and I went,
he's making sense and if you parse
analyze yogi sayings,
he does make sense.
He's credited with.
It's too crowded.
Nobody goes there anymore.
Well,
there's a story there that the Yankees,
after a night game,
we'll go out to dinner.
They'd be at the stadium early to either
go through the lineup of the opposing
team or get treated for some ailment or
wrapped their knees.
If it was mickey mantle or whatever
and after the game they'd all go out to
dinner and there was this one restaurant
in Cleveland that always was open and
always had a place for him after a game
and they all went there when it became
known that the Yankees eat here,
no advertising or word of mouth and they
went one time and there was no place at
the end for them so they didn't go there
anymore or go.
It's too crowded.
Nobody goes there anymore.
Meaning us.
Yogi makes sense.
I really don't think steroids are as big
a problem as the presses made them,
and if they are,
we've got a picture on steroids.
Throwing to a batter on steroids is
hitting to a field or on steroids.
Um,
you're looking for not one upsmanship.
Tony Gwen will tell you,
years ago the padres used to have a bowl
of Ben Fetterman's and their clubhouse
like m's.
You pop them,
didn't help the padres at all.
And I've talented.
Ain't gonna help nothing.
Your talent am I getting be a little
edge,
but so will a spit ball.
Baseball was always dealt in edges.
The phillies used to raise their third
base,
foul line,
extra lime.
So that Richie Ashwyn's bunks with state
there,
the Cleveland Indians used to grow the
grass higher at third base.
So Al Rosen,
the third baseman wouldn't break his,
his nose or his fingers on every ground
ball.
It would slow it down.
Nineteen 62 playoffs between the dodgers
and the giants.
By that time,
Los Angeles dodgers,
San Francisco giants,
they ordered the base pass so maury
wills couldn't get off to a fast start
and steel basis.
That's illegal.
Steroids aren't I,
you know.
All right.
I,
I don't get that excited about it.
I'm sorry.
You know,
and I'm so old that when I heard the
word drugs the first time I thought they
were talking about aspirin.